Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass Nummer 187. 187, wir wollen sprechen über den internationalen Fußball und vielleicht bekomme ich auch meine Sprachstörungen in Griff. Mal sehen. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Rasenfunk-Hörerinnen und Hörer. Wir tun jetzt einfach so, als wäre das hier live und das wird jetzt einfach genauso im Podcast landen. Tja, manchmal verhaspelt sich der Moderator seines Namens, Max Jakob Ost, der Etgenetzer auf Twitter, schon bei der Begrüßung. Deshalb sind wir doch alle sehr froh, ich am allermeisten, dass ich hier nicht den meisten Redenanteil haben soll, sondern meine Gäste. Und da habe ich auch in dieser Woche eine schöne Runde, die ich begrüßen darf, zum einen Mario Rieker, unter anderem von der ZAUN und natürlich vom Serie Amore Podcast, einem Podcast mit einem allein schon wunderschönen Titel. Hallo Mario.
Hi, grüß dich.
Schön, dass du hier bist. Außerdem begrüße ich ganz herzlich Alex Truica. Wir kennen ihn natürlich auch schon. Er ist unter anderem beim Tiki Taka Fußball Podcast, ist ein Experte für die spanische Liga. Hallo Alex. Grüße zurück und ich begrüße Uli Hebel. Die 50 Prozent der Hebel Brothers sind heute wieder hier. Premier League natürlich, ihr kennt ihn von der ZAUN. Hallo Uli, schön, dass du hier bist. Bist du diese böse Zunge? Naja, das klären wir wann anders. Und dann begrüße ich, am Telefon zugeschaltet, natürlich aus Paris, woher auch sonst. Alexis Menuge, hallo Alexis. Sehr schön, dass ich euch alle wieder hier habe. Wir machen es wie beim letzten Mal. Ihr kämpft jetzt um meine Aufmerksamkeit und damit ja eigentlich um die der Hörerinnen und Hörer. Darum geht es ja eigentlich. Alexis, du darfst mal beginnen. Warum müssten wir unbedingt als allererstes über die Ligue 1 sprechen?
Ja, weil die Ligue 1, auch wenn die Bundesliga dieses Mal nicht in der Runde ist, aber mittlerweile für mich stärker als die Bundesliga ist. Man braucht nur die Ergebnisse im Europapokal sehen. Ich will damit sagen, dass erst einmal das Niveau, die Konkurrenzfähigkeit, besser geworden ist als vor zwei, drei Jahren. Und nicht, weil Messi jetzt in Paris spielt, sondern weil man offensiver spielt. Die Einstellung hat sich ein bisschen geändert. Also nicht nur mehr betonieren. Wenig Null-Null mittlerweile. Sondern man hat knapp drei Tore im Schnitt. Man hatte noch zwei, zwei vor fünf, sechs Jahren. Also eine komplett andere Einstellung bei vielen Trainern. Und so hat man viele spannende Spiele. Natürlich hat man in dieser Saison Paris Saint-Germain, der nicht überragenspielerisch, aber seine Siege erholt. Dass man nicht viel Spannung hat ganz oben. Aber dahinten ist es richtig eng. Und es wird auch eng bleiben bis Saisonende. Und man sieht auch auf der europäischen Bühne 16 Spiele in Folge ungeschlagen, die französischen Vereine. Das hatten wir schon seit Jahrzehnten nicht mehr gefüllt zumindest.
Na okay, das war ein flammendes Plädoyer. Uli, was ist in der Premier League alles so passiert, was wir unbedingt besprechen müssen?
Zwei Gründe. Zum einen, es gibt, glaube ich, nirgends mehr prominentere Personalwechsel in den letzten Wochen als in der Premier League. Und einige, die sich noch anschicken oder zumindest drohen zu passieren. Zum zweiten, wenn der Drücker anfängt, dann schalten alle deine Hörer und Hörerinnen ab und es will ja niemand.
Ne, das wollen wir nicht. Alex, du musst dich jetzt sofort natürlich dann rechtfertigen dürfen. Warum ist La Liga wichtiger als alles, was Uli Hebel uns zu erzählen hat?
Direkt mit einer Spitze eingestiegen, der Hebel in den Podcast. Unglaublich. Ja, La Liga ist tatsächlich spannend, weil es ein sehr, sehr großes Thema an diesem Wochenende, oder besser gesagt am Montag, gab. Das ist natürlich Schawis Rückkehr zum FC Barcelona. Überstrahlt alles. Und dementsprechend gibt es da in La Liga in dieser Episode ganz besonders viel zu besprechen.
Mario, Serie A, was war los?
Wir hatten das Derby della Madonnina zwischen AC und Inter. Wir haben Milan, das hat seinen eigenen Startrekord geknackt. Wir haben Napoli, das weiterhin oben mitspielt. Wir haben eine neue Trainer-Kranne in der Serie A mit Andriy Shevchenko und ein Simeone Junior, der bombt.
Boah, Leute, da habt ihr es mir jetzt schwer gemacht. Ich würde sagen, wenn jemand sagt, dass eine Liga besser ist als die Bundesliga, und wir alle fünf hier wissen besser als jeder andere, dass die Bundesliga natürlich die beste Liga der Welt ist, der deutsche Fußball ist unübertroffen, dann soll sich Alexis Menuge jetzt mal verteidigen. Alexis, halte das Plädoyer für die Liga. Was hat sich denn, seitdem wir das letzte Mal miteinander gesprochen haben, so alles getan? Damals haben wir noch darüber geredet, dass nicht ordentlich trainiert wird. Und die Spieler, die in die Bundesliga kommen, Probleme haben. Jetzt willst du mir erzählen, die Liga 1 sei besser als die Bundesliga. Also entscheide dich mal.
Ja, weil die Bundesliga auch meistens überschätzt wird. Das ist einfach Fakt. Da sieht man ja, was die Bundesliga für Spiele sagt in dieser Saison und auch im Europapokal. Aber das ist was anderes. Bleiben wir bei der Liga 1. Ja, ich meine, es gibt einen gewissen Einfluss von ausständischen Trainern, wie Betta Boss, der eh schon unter Druck geraten ist am Wochenende, weil trotzdem auch dieses Pressing gegen Pressing mitgebracht wird, wie Niko Kovac in Monaco oder Jorge Sampaoli, Paul-Napit Marseille. Leider erwartet man auch irgendwas von Marcio Pochettino, aber seit einem Jahr kommt gar nichts von ihm spielerisch gesehen. Aber vielleicht kommt dann noch was, damit die Liga auch davon profitiert. Aber man hat schon das Gefühl auch, dass es anders ist, vielleicht seit dieser Pandemie-Pause mit dem Lockdown. Die Liga 1 ist die einzige Liga, und da muss ich mich schon stören als Franzose. Die Liga wurde abgebrochen nach dem 27. Spieltag. Und danach wurde gar nicht mehr gespielt, nicht bis zum Ende, sondern auch nicht mehr tatsächlich, hat man die Saison zu Ende offiziell gebracht. Und seitdem hat sich schon die Metallität zum Fußball, zum Profifußball, nicht geändert, aber doch ein Stück verändert, aber im positiven Sinne. In der Intensität bei den Trainingseinheiten, ich glaube, dass die französischen Trainer auch diese Pause genutzt haben, um auch zu sehen, wie die anderen in den europäischen Ländern arbeiten. Das hat schon für einen positiven Effekt gesorgt. Da hat man schon auch gesehen, wie die Mannschaften zurückkamen in der neuen Saison letztes Jahr mit deutlich mehr Tore, deutlich mehr Torchancen und keine Mannschaft mehr, die sich versteckt hat. Sondern egal ob PSG oder Troyes oder Brest, die spielen einfach Fußball, wollen nach vorne brechen, haben auch keine Angst mehr vor den Favoriten. So hat sich mental, technisch, taktisch schon einiges geändert. Man hat auch einige prominente Namen dazu geholt in der Liga 1 mit Philipp Hollande und Boateng aus deutscher Sicht. Das wäre vor ein paar Jahren nicht möglich gewesen. Aber ich glaube schon, dass diese ausländischen Trainer, die bekannt sind, auch dafür sorgen, dass die Liga 1 immer stärker wird. Das hat auch Jean Boateng bestätigt an dieser Woche bei seinem Twitter-Account. Deswegen können wir froh sein, dass man wieder nach einer kleinen Pause von den europäischen Top 5 Ligen sprechen darf und nicht nur vier.
Interessanter Befund. Da würde ich dann gerne in den anderen Segmenten auch nochmal von den anderen hören, ob sie auch das Gefühl haben, die Corona-Unterbrechung der Ligen dort hat etwas grundsätzlich so ein bisschen an der Statik verändert. Aber dann lass mal kurz bei der Liga 1 bleiben. Oben grüßt uns wie immer Pégé mit 10 Punkten Vorsprung, weil es die Verfolger einfach nicht schaffen, regelmäßig zu gewinnen. Also es gibt nur eine –nein, Entschuldigung –es gibt drei Mannschaften insgesamt, die die letzten zwei Ligaspiele gewonnen haben. Pégé ist eine davon, dann Montpellier und noch Brest auf Tabellenplatz 17. Über Pégé sprechen wir hier sehr viel. Wir haben das letzte Mal über den Spielstil von Pochettino gesprochen und den nicht erkennbaren Spielstil. Was ist denn deiner Meinung nach wichtig zu wissen, was jetzt passiert ist in der Ligue 1, vielleicht auch unabhängig mal von Paris?
Man hat einfach auch das Gefühl, dass es schwierig ist, auch, wie du sagst, dass Mannschaften, auch große Mannschaften, also Namen zumindest, wie Monaco, Marseille, Lyon, in der Lage sind, zwei, drei Spiele hintereinander zu gewinnen. Das ist sehr schwer. Das sind Mannschaften, die –ich habe vorher von Mentalität gesprochen, und das betrifft auch zum Beispiel den Europapokal. Früher haben die französischen Vereine, die Europa League eigentlich gar nicht so richtig gespielt oder bestritten. Die haben einfach die B11 hingeschickt oder die C11, um die Mannschaft zu schonern in den Hinblick aufs Wochenende, obwohl man die ganze vorige Saison gekämpft hatte, um überhaupt europäisch vertreten zu sein. Und dann war man in der Europa League und hat man die einfach nicht ernst genommen. Das ist anders geworden. Und da spielen ganz klar die europäischen Trainer Kovac, Samp-Pauli und Bosnio Rolle, die wollen die Europa League nicht nur beschreiten, die wollen die Europa League gewinnen. Die Jungs zum Beispiel sind ja schon fürs Achtelfinale qualifiziert, das erste und einzige Verein. Und das zeigt, dass auch diese Mannschaften vielleicht dann am Wochenende, weil sie alles geben am Donnerstag in der Europa League, gewisse Frische fehlt und dass sie halt Probleme haben, zwei, drei, vier Spiele hintereinander zu gewinnen. Aber nichtsdestotrotz diese Konkurrenzfähigkeit, diese Nachhaltigkeit, die ist schon zu spüren. Und auch wenn man jetzt Nizza, Lens und Rennes da oben haben, was schon überraschend ist, vor allem bei Lens und Nizza, die ja relativ neu sind. Lens war ja auch Steigerletzte Saison. Aber die spielen auch so einen Fußball mit richtig viel Leidenschaft und haben eh die besten Fans in Frankreich, wenn nicht mehr. Und das pusht einfach einen ganzen Verein. Und wenn sie so im Flow sind, dann können sie einiges schaffen. Und profitieren natürlich, wie du sagst, von Mannschaften, die nicht konstant sind oder nicht konstant genug, wie United Marseille, wie Monaco. Und dann gibt es andere Vereine, wie Niza, der über einen reichten Engländer viel Geld zu verfügen stellt. So hat man eine schlagkräftige Mannschaft aufgebaut. Sollte Niza, die Champions League oder die Europa League reichen, dann wird im kommenden Sommer noch mehr Geld vorhanden sein, um die Mannschaften noch einmal zu feststellen und dann vielleicht für Paris als eine richtige Gefahr zu werden.
Das hast du uns ja in der letzten Ausgabe der Ligatur auch schon angekündigt, dass Niza innerhalb der nächsten zwei, drei Jahre durchaus mal in die Champions League kommen könnte. Jetzt stehen sie aktuell auf Tabellenplatz 3. Du hast aber damals auch darüber gesprochen, dass das jetzt gar nicht so gut wäre, wenn die größeren Vereine in Anführungszeichen, also Olympique Marseille, Olympique Lyon und von den Möglichkeiten her muss man da sicherlich auch den AS Monaco dazu zählen. Wenn die sich eben nicht international qualifizieren, denn du hast da die schlechte Bilanz der französischen Teams ausgenommen PSG und Olympique Lyon zitiert. Ich glaube von 99 möglichen Punkten hattest du gesagt, haben in den internationalen Wettbewerben französische Mannschaften, die nicht Paris oder Lyon waren, nur 9 Punkte geholt. Wie siehst du denn jetzt dann die aktuelle Entwicklung? Das scheint ja dann darauf rauszulaufen, dass man dann immer wieder Europapokal-Teilnehmer aus der französischen Liga hat, mit denen man vielleicht nicht gerechnet hat, die aber dann in der Folge-Saison dafür so ein bisschen die Rechnung bezahlen.
Das ist genau perfekt zusammengefasst. Ich meine, das macht sehr monarko Lyon jetzt die Europaliga-Streiten. Und dass sie diesen Wettbewerb so ernst nehmen, wäre vielleicht nicht der Fall gewesen, wenn Mannschaften wie Benizer oder letztes Saisonstart de Thiernoir in Europapokal gewesen wären. Weil für diese Mannschaften war es eine Art Bonus und die wollten als Priorität einfach den Klassenerhalt in der Liga schaffen. Weil Lyon macht sehr monarko durch andere finanzielle Mittel, durch eine schlatträchtige Truppe. Da hat man schon das Gefühl, dass diese Teams einfach Liga und Europa League in Beigenberg werden sehr weit kommen können. Aber wie man sieht, die Mannschaften, die unter der Woche im Europapokal unterwegs sind, haben Probleme in ihrer jeweiligen Liga oder ihre jeweiligen Ligaspielen zu überzeugen bzw. die Ergebnisse zu erzielen, die man sich hier erhofft und erwartet. Und an dieser Tatsache, dass man diese drei Europa League dabei hat, sorgt schon dafür, dass auch jetzt die Ergebnisse wieder stimmen, dass diese desastrose Bilanz wieder aufgebessert wird. Und wie gesagt, in der Urheberwertung allein dieser Saison steht Frankreich von den Ergebnissen her nur hinter England. Vor Spanien, vor Italien und sowieso vor der Bundesliga. Also das ist schon vielleicht ein Moment auch damit, glaube ich, aber nicht. Weil wie gesagt, man hat das Gefühl, durch den Einfluss anderer Trainer, ausländischer Trainer, durch vielleicht auch eine gewisse… Man ist sich bewusst geworden, dass man alles ernst nehmen sollte, also jedes Spiel, aber auch jedes Wettbewerb. Und auch, dass man offensive ausgerichtet werden sollte, um auch Spaß zu haben, um seine Fans zu begeistern. Und, dass man mit einem 0-0-Mikael Weiss schwer leben kann, egal wie der Verein heißt, was früher eher ein Gewinn war, mit diesem Ergebnis. Also es ist einfach ein Mentalitätswechsel. Deswegen glaube ich nicht an eine Momentaufnahme. Und deswegen hoffe ich auch, dass diese vier gelandete Mannschaften, also Paris, Monaco, Marseille, Lyon, jedes Jahr im Europavokal dabei sind, am besten der Champions League. Aber wie gesagt, ich glaube, dass Wagnica in der Champions League kommt oder rennt. Und beide Mannschaften mit einem reichen Eigentümer. Dann können die sich auch richtig verstärken und dann auch für Überraschung sorgen.
Jetzt haben wir in der letzten Woche oder in der letzten Ausgabe, Entschuldigung, da hatten wir noch ein sehr enges Tabellenbild. Da lagen viele Mannschaften sehr eng beieinander. So ein bisschen entzerrt sich das langsam. Es ist aber weiter so, dass zwischen Platz 3 und Platz 11 nur drei Punkte liegen. Also sprich, da ist auch noch sehr schwer jetzt Vorhersagen zu treffen, wie da die Tendenz innerhalb der Liga ist, in der Stärke. Was mir aber immer wieder auffällt, wenn ich mir die Tabelle der Ligue 1 angucke, ist die Positionierung von Giron d'Ain Bordeaux. Die haben zwar, wenn man so will, auch nur drei Punkte oder vier Punkte Rückstand auf Platz 12. Sie haben aber mit 12 Punkten aus 13 Spielen auch wirklich nicht viel herausgeholt. Und das Problem scheint so ein bisschen die Unentschieden zu sein. Zwei Siege, sechs Unentschieden, fünf Niederlagen aktuell eben Tabellen Platz 18 in dieser 20er Liga. Was ist denn bei Bordeaux los?
Ja, seit etlichen Jahren eigentlich gibt es Probleme sportlich, aber vor allem bei der Vereinsführung. Man hat in der vergangenen Saison mieten in der Saison den Eigentümer gewechselt von einer amerikanischen Inventorenfirma. Das ist Jérard Lopez, der Lille übernahm vor ein paar Jahren. Das ist ein skrupulöser Unternehmer, der kein Geld machen will mit dem Fußball, aber es irgendwie schafft, auch starkkräftige Mannschaften aufzubauen mit vielen Leihen. Das hat bei Lille wirklich gut funktioniert. Jetzt bei Bordeaux hat er das auch sagen und hat natürlich spektakulär auf dem Transfermarkt zugeschlagen. Auf dem Trainermarkt mit Wladimir Petkovic, der ja mit der Schweiz für Foucault gesorgt hat bei der letzten EM. Aber es funktioniert nicht, weil auch diese Mannschaft einfach viel zu viele Wechsel angenommen hat. Jetzt im Sommer mit 12, 13 Neuzugänge, aber auch mehr als 15 Abgänge. Diese Mannschaft hat sich noch nicht gefunden. Das ist natürlich schade, weil diese Mannschaft ist einer der dreilichsten Reichten in Frankreich. Sie war mehrfach schon Meister. Sie war sogar im Finale Moufacap gegen den FC Bayern damals mit Xabre Pappard. Man hat aber das Gefühl, dass diese Mannschaft noch weit entfernt ist vom damaligen Niveau. Letzte Saison war schon sehr eng beim Kampf um den Klassenerhalt. Lange Zeit haben wir gedacht, dass diese Mannschaft absteigt. In dieser Saison ist es wieder richtig eng. Das ist umso mehr schade, weil das Fan-Potenzial bei Gironne enorm ist. Das hat man gegen PSG am Samstag gesehen, wo das Stadion fast ausverkauft war. Aber man weiß auch, dass diese Mannschaft über tolle Fans verfügt. Super Stadion, aber wenn PSG nicht kommt oder macht, ist das Stadion halbleer. Oder zum Dreiviertel leer. Man weiß nicht, ob Bordeaux mittel- und langfristig wieder oben anknüpfen kann. Also kurzfristig ausgeschlossen, es geht nur um den Klassenerhalt in dieser Saison. Aber man hat einfach viel zu viel Unruhe gehabt um den Verein. Die letzten Jahre keine klare Struktur, kein klares Konzept, keine klare Stabilität. So dass diese Mannschaft öfters mit dem Klassenerhalt zu tun hat, als mit dem Kampf um die europäischen Plätze. Und wie gesagt, das betrifft auch andere Traditionsvereine, wie zum Beispiel Saint-Etienne, der gerade E-Lec da ist. Aber man erhofft sich auch für die Konkurrenzfähigkeit und für die tollen Namen, die es in Frankreich gibt, dass Pjolanda irgendwann mal wieder da oben anknüpfen kann. Aber wie gesagt, in den nächsten zwei, drei Jahren hat es ausgeschlossen und wäre auch keine große Überraschung mehr, wenn dieser Verein in der nächsten Saison absteigen sollte.
Das sind keine schönen Aussichten. Wer ist denn für dich aktuell die größte Überraschung in der Liga, die vielleicht auch so ein bisschen unter dem Radar schwebt? Welches Team würdest du da nennen oder welche Personalien wäre da interessant?
Ja, auf jeden Fall vom Verein her. Racing Club de Lens, wie gesagt, ist in der zweiten Saison erst als Aufsteiger. Man war vier, fünf Jahre in der zweiten Liga, immerhin französischer Meister geworden damals, 1998. Und in dieser Saison ist Lens nicht zufällig da oben. Es ist eine Mannschaft, die wirklich tollen Fußball spielt, mit dem selben Trainer seit mehreren Jahren, Franck Eze, völlig unbekannt in Europa, ist mir schon klar. Aber er macht eine riesige Arbeit. Es ist eine Mannschaft, die mit sehr viel Leidenschaft spielt, die sich im Sommer clever verstärkt hat, mit dem Skandalspiel aus Augsburg, Danzow, der Abwehrservice bei Lens und er hat sich sofort eingefügt, hat sofort den Standort gefunden. Die Leidenschaft der Fans der Leute im Norden Frankreich hatte Lens schon letzte Saison als Meister aus Norden Frankreich. Vielleicht wird Lens sogar Meister der Herzen in dieser Saison, weil er nicht drin ist natürlich mit PSG. Das ist schon eine große Überraschung. Aber ich würde auch sagen, momentan rennt die Mannschaft der Stunde. 4-1 gegen Lyon, es hätte auch 8-1 ausgehen müssen am Sonntag. Das war die Revanche für den Trainer Bruno Genesio, der jahrelang in Lyon war als Spieler und als Trainer, der heute auf dem Morgen entlassen wurde aufgrund des Trucks. Der Fan war nicht beliebt und das war dann die Revanche für ihn. Von den Persönlichkeiten her sehe ich eher die beiden Mannschaften, Lens und Rennes, aber es gibt keinen Spieler, der überragt gerade bei diesen Mannschaften, weil die sind zwei Teams, die wie eine Einheit auftreten. Da gibt es keinen Spieler, der überragt, sondern wirklich man überzeugt und man sorgt für die Überraschung fast jedes Wochenende als Mannschaft.
Also Lens, Tabellenplatz 2, Rennes aktuell Tabellenplatz 5, die kann man sich definitiv mal angucken. Vielen Dank dir, Alexi. Dann lasst mal nach Spanien blicken. Das ist jetzt spannend für uns alle Beteiligten, weil ihr alle bis kurz vorhin nicht wisst, über welche nächste Liga wir sprechen werden. Aber ich glaube, an diesem gewissen Trainerwechsel, diesem Scharvi, kommen wir dann vielleicht doch nicht länger vorbei in dieser Ligatur. Alex, wird jetzt alles wieder gut beim FC Barcelona?
Man muss schon zugeben, der Verein war am Boden, war also wirklich der komplette Verein der FC Barcelona. Ja, der Depression verfallen, wenn man so möchte. Und Scharvi erweckt so ein bisschen den Club wieder zum Leben. Zumindest war das am Montag der Fall, als er präsentiert wurde. Zehn bis zwölftausend Zuschauer waren im Stadion bei der Präsentation des neuen Trainers. Sie haben sogar Gesänge und Jubel und Lieder angestimmt. Also das war wirklich eine ganz, ganz besondere Nummer, die es da im Camp Nou gibt. Natürlich werden da immer Spieler und Trainer präsentiert. Das ist also nichts Außergewöhnliches. In Deutschland kennt man das wahrscheinlich nicht. In Spanien oder zumindest bei Barcelona und Real Madrid ist es ja normal, dass Neuzugänge im Camp Nou den Fans präsentiert werden. Aber dass ein Trainer so begeistert empfangen wird, dass die Fans ja, wie gesagt, Lieder anstimmen, dass sogar Laporta und Scharvi selbst ein bisschen mitsingen, das war eine ganz, ganz besondere Atmosphäre. Und das zeigt schon, das könnte so ein bisschen ein Erweckungserlebnis sein für den Barcelonismo.
Aber was hat denn Scharvi in sportlicher Hinsicht vorzuweisen, außer dass er natürlich ein grandioser Spieler war und auch eine wichtige Figur für diesen Verein? Kann man darüber überhaupt eine seriöse Aussage treffen bei seinen bisherigen Trainerstationen?
Ich glaube, das kann man nur, wenn man katarische Liga verfolgt hat. Und ich denke mal, das hat sich keiner von uns hier im Podcast. Also ich möchte mir das wirklich nicht anmaßen, ihn fundiert bewerten zu können. Natürlich hört man sehr viel Gutes. Er hat unglaublich viele Pokale gewonnen. In Katar ist er erfolgreich mit dem Alsat Sports Club gewesen. Aber ich habe nie über 90 Minuten oder nie ein Spiel von Alsat gesehen. Deswegen kann ich mir das nicht anmaßen, das zu bewerten. Nichtsdestotrotz kommt er mit sehr viel Vorschusslorbeeren und er kommt mit einer sehr großen Erwartungshaltung. Denn er steht ja für bestimmte Dinge, nämlich diese Barca-DNA, die zuletzt vielleicht Pep Guardiola so ein bisschen in eine Vereine reingebracht hat. Und seitdem ist die nicht mehr so da. Also er verkörpert diese Spielphilosophie, nachdem sich der FC Barcelona und alle Fans einfach sehnen. Tiki-Taka, das Kurzpass-Spiel, Ruego de Posición, das Positionsspiel, dass der Ball zirkuliert. All das, dieser schöne attraktive Fußball, für den Barcelona steht, den es aber seit einigen Jahren, wenn man ehrlich ist, einfach nicht mehr gibt. Also die Ergebnisse passen nicht, aber auch die Spielweise passt nicht. Und Xavi steht halt für all das, oder zumindest hofft man, dass es wieder dazu kommt.
Ehrlich gesagt klingt das für mich nach einem Cocktail, der auch grandios schiefgehen könnte, gerade weil die Erwartungshaltung so groß ist. Ich glaube, wir müssen aber an der Stelle dann auch noch mal über Coman sprechen und seine kurze Zeit jetzt beim FC Barcelona. Wie würdest du die denn jetzt dann zusammenfassen? Er hatte es ja auch wirklich nicht leicht, wenn wir uns allein mal angucken, welche Spieler verloren wurden aus den unterschiedlichsten Gründen vor dieser Saison.
Ja, Barca geht quasi von einer Vereinslegende zu anderen. Auch Coman ist ja eine absolute Ikone des Barcelonismus. Aber eben, das hat einfach nicht so gut geklappt. Also auch er hat immer wieder Johann Greuf bemüht und gesagt, ja, wir spielen natürlich nach dem greufischen Fußballmodell. Aber es waren einfach im Endeffekt nur leere Worte. Auf dem Platz hat man das nicht wirklich gesehen. Natürlich gab es immer Spiele, in denen Barca gut gespielt hat. Aber die Konstanz fehlte komplett. Und auch unterm Strich hat er enttäuscht. Ich glaube, das kann man schon sagen. Und auch deswegen war der Basseleinismus so ein bisschen in der Depression. Die Ergebnisse stimmten nicht. Auf seinen PKs hat er sich immer sehr fatalistisch gegeben. Die waren immer sehr negativ. Er war enorm unter Druck, er war genervt. Also die komplette Stimmung im Verein stimmte überhaupt nicht mehr unter Koeman. Und jetzt hofft man natürlich, dass es den kompletten Turnaround gibt. Stimmung im Verein, was der Trainer an sich verkörpert, was er mitbringt, die Ideen. Und natürlich soll dann auch der Fußball besser werden. Also man erhofft sich sehr, sehr viel von Xavi. All diese Dinge, die es unter Koeman zuletzt nicht mehr gab.
Würde schon mal helfen, nicht gegen Celta Vigo in der 95. Minute das 3 zu 3 zu kassieren. Aber das war ja noch vor dem Erweckungserlebnis durch Xavi. Deswegen dürfen wir das natürlich da nicht mit reinrechnen. Über Barca werden wir sowieso noch sehr viel sprechen. Generell ist es ja so, dass wir im La Liga-Segment sehr häufig über ähnliche Vereine sprechen. Gibt es denn welche jenseits der großen drei? Atletico, Barca, Real? Wo du sagst, lass mal damit einsteigen in dieses Segment.
Alexi hat das ja auch schön gesagt. In Frankreich gibt es so viele spannende Vereine, spannende Dinge, die da passieren. Das ist in Spanien natürlich auch so. Natürlich nimmt Xavi diese Einstellung des neuen Trainers sehr viel Raum ein, auch bei uns im Podcast. Aber es gibt andere super interessante Dinge. Beispielsweise ist der Tabellenführer Real Sociedad. Das ist schon mal ein Ausrufezeichen schlechthin, dass da eben ein Verein steht, der nicht Barcelona, Real Madrid oder Atletico heißt. Oder auch nicht mal Sevilla, sondern mit Real Sociedad ein besonderer Tabellenführer. Dann ist die andere Top 3 natürlich normal mit Real, Sevilla und Atletico, aber schon danach folgt auf Platz 6 Rayo Vallecano, ein Aufsteiger, und auf Platz 7 Ossasuna, eine Mannschaft, die traditionell eher gegen den Abstieg spielt. Also viele spannende Dinge, die da vorgehen, auch tabellarisch in La Liga, über die man absolut sprechen kann.
Dann lass doch genau das mal machen. Man muss noch dazu sagen, dass Real Sociedad ein Spiel mehr hat als Real, Sevilla und Atletico, die allesamt dahinter liegen. Das war wegen verschobener Spiele. Ist das der Fall? Das ist noch nicht ganz das finale Tabellenbild. Aber was macht denn dann Real Sociedad so besonders? Ein bisschen haben wir schon über sie gesprochen in den letzten Wochen.
Also wenn du mich fragst, warum sind gerade die Erste und nicht andere Mannschaften, dann würde ich sagen, die gute Abwehr. Es ist wirklich erstaunlich, wie häufig Real Sociedad zu Null gewinnt. Wenn sie gewinnen, gewinnen sie fast immer in La Liga zu Null. Ich glaube, nur in einem Spiel haben sie nicht die Null gehalten. Also acht Siege aus 13 Spielen ist ja eh schon eine Top-Bilanz, aber in sieben der acht Spiele gewannen sie zu Null. Also sprich, sie brauchen sehr wenig, sie sind tatsächlich ziemlich minimalistisch unterwegs. Es gab drei oder vier Spiele, die 1-0 gewonnen wurden, aber wenn hinten eben die Null steht und du immer dieses eine Tor mehr machst, das ist jetzt eine alte abgedroschene Phrase, dann verlierst du schon mal nicht und in der Regel gewinnst du die Spiele natürlich. Also es ist nicht der allerberauschendste Fußball, aber es ist eben ein sehr erfolgreicher Fußball aktuell. Und das ist erstaunlich, denn wirklich abwehrstark hat man Real Sociedad eigentlich nicht in Erinnerung.
Ja, ich habe mir da bei der letzten Sendung aufgeschrieben, risikoarmer Fußball, aber sehr erfolgreich und das trotz vieler Ausfälle, die man aktuell hat. Also das ist das, was man von Real Sociedad so ein bisschen bekommt und das hat sich jetzt auch durch die letzten Wochen noch bestätigt, das, was wir damals besprochen haben. Was ist über Rayo Vaekano zu sagen? Ich habe im Hinterkopf, dass da vor allem die Heimstärke auch eine Rolle gespielt hat.
Wenn mein Podcast-Kollegin Nils Kern jetzt im Podcast wäre, der würde richtig schwärmen von Rayo. Das ist so ein bisschen das Team der Saison, auch wenn Real Sociedad natürlich erster ist, aber als Aufsteiger Rayo als sechster Platz, auf dem sechsten Platz zu sein, ist schon herausragend. Man konnte den FC Barcelona zu Hause schlagen, auch wenn das nichts mehr Besonderes ist, wenn man ehrlich ist, aber trotzdem natürlich eine grandiose Story für Rayo. Und grundsätzlich eine auch grandiose Story ist Falcaro, der fast schon vergessene, alte Mittelstürmer aus Kolumbien, der ja bei Galatasaray jetzt irgendwie dann zwei, drei Jahre war und mehr oder weniger komplett von der Bildfläche verschwand, jetzt zur Rayo zurückkam und richtig gut funktioniert. Ich meine, fünf Saisontore hat er schon, mit, ich glaube, nur elf Schüssen aufs Tor. Also das ist ein Fuchs vor dem Tor, der einfach weiß, wo die Kiste steht. Und solche Stürmer gibt es in La Liga immer wieder. Und das ist einfach eine schöne Feel-Good-Story. Für Rayo sowieso eine klasse Sache, so einen alten Fox in the Box da zurückzubekommen nach La Liga. Und dass der dann direkt auch funktioniert und wichtige, entscheidende Tore schießt. Also Barca hat er abgeschossen beim 1-0. Im Bernabeu war er zehn Minuten im Einsatz. Danach leider verletzt raus, aber in diesen zehn Minuten macht er auch das Tor gegen Real Madrid. Also das Rayo ist eine tolle Story in Spanien. Sie spielen vor allem sehr unerschrocknen, sehr mutigen, sehr forschen Angriffsfußball. Also die laufen, kämpfen, geben Vollgas, verstecken sich nicht, sind überhaupt nicht defensiv oder destruktiv. Und das macht schon wirklich Laune, diese Mannschaft zuzusehen. Und deswegen ist der sechste Platz aktuell auch wirklich verdient.
Zu Hause noch ungeschlagen jetzt nach 13 Spielen, die Rayo absolviert hat. Sechs davon zu Hause, fünf Siege, ein Unentschieden, 13 zu zwei Tore. Auf der anderen Seite ist dann auswärts logischerweise ein bisschen das Problem. Da hat man erst einmal gewinnen können, fünf Niederlagen. Das heißt, das kann man eben sehr deutlich machen, diese Unterscheidung zwischen zu Hause und auswärts. Jetzt sprechen wir über einen Aufsteiger, und das ist natürlich eine super Leistung, so dazustehen. Du ordnest es ja schon richtig ein. Kann man aber begründen, warum das so, Rayo jetzt in diesem Fall so schwer fällt, das, was man zu Hause zeigt, auch auswärts zu wiederholen?
Grundsätzlich würde ich es damit begründen, dass jetzt, wo die Fans in allen Stadien da überall zurück sind, in egal welcher Liga man wieder diesen alten Heim- und Auswärtseffekt sieht, dass einfach viel mehr Heimspiele gewonnen werden von den Mannschaften. Ich meine ja, fast 60 Prozent ist da der Schnitt, so grundsätzlich quer durch die Ligen. Und diesen Effekt hast du jetzt auch in der Liga natürlich. Warum Rayo jetzt selbst zu Hause so viel besser ist als auswärts, zumindest tabellarisch? Das Stadion gibt ja so viele Fans nicht her. Meistens sind so 6.000, 8.000, 12.000 im Stadion, so plus minus. Aber zu Hause fühlen sie sich warum auch immer einfach wohler. Ich würde es damit begründen, dass sie wie jede Mannschaft zu Hause einfach durch den Heimvorteil noch ein paar Prozent mehr rauskitzeln können. Natürlich hängt es auch davon ab, wen du zu Hause zu Gast hast und bei welchen Mannschaften du auswärts spielst. Wenn sie jetzt im Camp Nou gespielt hätten, statt zu Hause gegen Barca, wäre das Ganze vielleicht auch anders ausgegangen. So etwas spielt ja auch immer eine Rolle.
Das stimmt. Ich habe mir damit aber auch eine Überleitung gebaut, um ehrlich zu sein. Du hattest ja noch Ossasuna, die aktuell Tabellenplatz 7 belegen, genannt als eine der Überraschungen. Bei denen ist es nämlich fast umgedreht. Genau, ja. Die sind in der Auswärtstabelle auf Rang 3, haben aus sechs Spielen vier Siege, einen Unentschieden, eine Niederlage. Bei denen läuft das zu Hause nicht so gut. Kann man das begründen? Ist das jetzt ein Zufall des Spielplans? Ich habe jetzt natürlich nicht alle Spiele von Ossasuna im Kopf. Was sagt das über diese Mannschaft aus?
Für mich ist das tatsächlich ein bisschen eine Anomalie. Es ist jetzt nichts, wo ich sage, das wird A so bleiben. Grundsätzlich ist auch die Tabellenplatzierung sehr außergewöhnlich. Ich glaube aber nicht, dass sich das halten wird. Ossasuna wird abrutschen. Manchmal hast du einfach so einen Lauf, den man nicht erklären kann. Letztes Jahr erinnere ich mich, dass Cádiz als neuer Aufsteiger alle vier Auswärtsspiele gewonnen hat und alle zu Null. Auch das ist dann irgendwann komplett abgerissen und war nicht mehr zu halten. Manchmal gibt es diese Anomalien, dass eine Mannschaft, ein Underdog oder so eine Mittelklasse-Mannschaft plötzlich ein paar Spiele am Stück gewinnt, in dem Fall auswärts und zu Hause nicht, und dann höher steht. Ich glaube, das wird sich irgendwann ausgleichen. Auch diese verrückte Auswärtsbilanz wird sich irgendwann ausgleichen.
Okay, das haben wir ja durchaus in vielen Ligen, dass da zwischendurch mal jemand mitspielt. Ich erinnere mich an Champions League-Gesänge beim 1. FC Köln. Die waren auch noch etwas verfrüht, auch wenn sie sicherlich nicht ganz ernst gemeint waren. Eine Mannschaft, über die man immer mal widerspricht, wenn man auf Spanien blickt, aufgrund der Historie, ist der FC Valencia. Denen geht es jetzt nicht ganz so schlecht wie Giro d'Ambordo, über die wir vorhin schon gesprochen haben. Aber ich glaube, so ein paar Quervergleiche, also große Geschichte, früher auch international Erfolge gefeiert, standen ja in mehreren Champions League-Finals. Ich glaube, zwei Finalteile in drei Jahren waren das damals, rund um die Jahrtausendwende. Dann Probleme mit Stadionbau. Timo Hildebrandt haben wir alles, glaube ich, noch so ganz grob zumindest im Kopf. Die scheinen sich irgendwie zur grauen Maus von La Liga zu entwickeln, ohne zu spielen wie eine graue Maus. Also es passiert immer viel, auch in dieser Saison. 21 Tore geschossen, 20 kassiert. Das heißt, 41 Tore hat man in Spielen des FC Valencia schon sehen können, jetzt in 13 Spielen. Was ist zu denen zu sagen? Hat sich da was verändert im Vergleich zu den letzten Spielzeiten?
Also Valencia grundsätzlich hat ja einen neuen Trainer, Bordalas, und ich würde schon sagen, der macht einen guten Job. Tabellarisch klar, wenn du Zehntner bist, wirst du denken, ja das ist jetzt an der Tabelle nicht abzulesen, aber zumindest an den Fußballspielen finde ich schon, denn es herrscht ein ganz anderer Zug in den Spielen von Valencia. Bordalas ist ja bekannt dafür, dass er in den Mannschaften sein Cretafe zumindest kämpft, rennt, fightet, foult, sehr teilweise unsportlich spielt. Und wenn du das natürlich auf eine bessere Mannschaft umwandeln kannst, auf eine Mannschaft, die viel talentierter ist, dann kannst du damit auch Erfolge rausholen, weil sein Cretafe war immer sehr, sehr limitiert. Also einfach nicht die besten Fußballer. Und er hat jetzt bei Valencia viel, viel bessere Fußballer zur Verfügung. Und das schlägt sich schon in manchen Spielen wieder. Beispielsweise hätten sie um 1h gegen Real Madrid im Mestalla gewonnen. Da führten sie bis, ich glaube, zur 86. 1-0 und dann Real Madrid, wie immer, zwei späte Tore, zack, Spiel gedreht. Ziemlich unverdient. Also da waren sie schon sehr, sehr nah dran, real zu schlagen. Und jetzt am Wochenende gab es ein stürmisches 3-3 gegen Atletico. Und normalerweise würdest du sagen, ein Border-Last-Team, das auf ein Csolos-Simeone-Team trifft, da werden niemals mehr als zwei Tore fallen. Nee, das war ein richtiges Spektakel. Also und in dem Fall auch mit einem guten Ergebnis für Valencia. Denn in der Nachspielzeit trafen sie zum Ausgleich, haben da quasi Atletico ins Tal der Tränen gestürzt. Und das war wirklich ein Spiel, wo du merkst, okay, La Liga ist wirklich zurück, endlich wieder Fans im Stadion. Das hat einfach auch eine Auswirkung auf die Mannschaften grundsätzlich. Und da war wirklich Spektakel. Und du hast gesehen, Border-Last kann diesen FC Valencia schon ein bisschen zum Leben erwecken.
Ach ja, das ist so ein bisschen schon der Kontrast zur letzten Ligatur, wo nie ist noch das flammende Plädoyer dafür gehalten hat, wie schlecht La Liga ist im internationalen Vergleich. Er hat es unter anderem an Toren und so weiter festgemacht. Dieses 3 zu 3, das kann ich wirklich nur sehr empfehlen. Vor allem zum Ausgleichen der 95. Minute durch Hugo Duro kommt ja noch der Anschlusstreffer in der 91. Minute. Also wirklich innerhalb der letzten Spielminuten dieses Spiels wurde das dann noch zu einem Unentschieden bei Valencia. Da kann man, glaube ich, durchaus auch mal hingucken. Gibt es denn noch andere Mannschaften, wo du sagst, wenn wir jetzt auch in die unteren Tabellenregionen gucken, da lohnt ein näherer Blick drauf, weil sie überraschender stehen oder weil es da wichtige Themen gibt?
Ja, wenn wir schon vom 3 zu 3 sprechen, müssen wir natürlich dieses 3 zu 3 von Celta gegen Barca auch nochmal erwähnen, in dem Fall aber aus Sicht von Celta. Deswegen ist das so ein bisschen das Kontrastprogramm zum Auftritt von Nils. Bei mir gab es jetzt eben zwei spektakuläre 3 zu 3s am Wochenende.
Ich glaube, es liegt an dir.
Weiß ich nicht, aber ich stehe natürlich unter dem Eindruck dieser Partidasos, wie der Spanier sagt. Also absolute Topspiele, die hochklassig waren, dramatisch waren. Es gab auch in anderen Spielen viele späte Tore. Und eben bei Celta genau das Gleiche. Celta zur Pause 0-3 gegen Barca zurückgelegen. Und das war das Celta, das man von dieser Saison kennt, nämlich sie sind die schlechteste Heimannschaft der Liga. Also wir haben Rayo erwähnt als beste Heimannschaft oder eine sehr gute Heimannschaft. Celta war die schlechteste, liegt zur Pause gegen Barca 0-3 hinten. Dann würdest du sagen, ok, das Spiel ist rum. Nee, in der zweiten Halbzeit hat sich das Blatt komplett gewendet und Celta wurde irgendwie zu neuem Leben erweckt, woher auch immer das kam. Und da gab es auch den Ausgleichstreffer in der 95. Also ja, die Barca-Herzen wurden gebrochen von einer Mannschaft, die aber damit Erfahrung hatte. Gerade zu Hause gegen Barcelona hat Celta immer wieder so verrückte Spiele drin, wo sie Barca einfach ärgern. Also ich meine, von den letzten elf Spielen im Balaidos konnte Barca nur drei gewinnen, was ja schon keine gute Bilanz ist für so einen Großklub. Also da hast du gesehen, quasi in einem Spiel je Hälfte, was Celta Vigo ausmacht, das Celta Vigo der Zweigesichter. Sie haben immer Spiele drin wie vor der Halbzeit oder in der ersten Halbzeit, dieses 0-3, da waren sie einfach schwach und nicht auf dem Platz. Aber sie haben auch dieses fußballerische Potential, jede Mannschaft zu ärgern, je zweite Halbzeit. Und das ist auch so ein bisschen manchmal ein Team to watch, aber eben nicht immer, weil du nie weißt, welche Zelte du bekommst. Weil eigentlich haben sie Potential, aber sie rufen es zu selten ab. Und deswegen sind sie auch nur 15. aktuell. Also eigentlich sehr enttäuschend.
Das war doch jetzt mal ein schöner Blick jenseits der ganz großen Namen in La Liga. Vielen Dank dafür. Lasst uns über die Serie A sprechen mit Mario Rieker. Da gab es unter anderem einen Mailander Derby. Das hat den Spieltag, den 12. war das, beschlossen. Ein 1 zu 1 wurde das am Ende. Ich will jetzt aber gar nicht vorgeben, dass wir über Mailand sprechen müssen. Mario, was sind denn die wichtigen Themen deiner Meinung nach? Du hast ja vorhin schon eine Synopsis gegeben. Deswegen, weiß ich, bist du immer perfekt vorbereitet.
Ja, man muss trotzdem auch über das Derby sprechen, wie ich finde. Das hat auch in den Gazetten für viel Aufregung und natürlich für viele Schlagzeilen danach gesorgt. Es gab zwei riesengroße schöne Choreos von beiden Seiten. Der Ultras, die dann auch tatsächlich dem Pflegepersonal gewidmet wurden. Also Statement auf jeden Fall in einem solch wichtigen Spiel. Die Choreos, die auch wirklich schick anzusehen waren, dann Ärzten und Pflegerinnen und Ärztinnen zu widmen. Genau, und es war furios. Also es war kein Abtasten. Es ist die erste Halbzeit, da ging es hin und her. Ein Elfmeter Tor, ein Eigentor, ein verschossener Elfmeter und ein Hakan Çalanolu, der sicherlich bei den Roseneri, den Roten und Schwarzen, keine Freunde mehr finden wird in seiner Karriere.
Okay, das musst du, glaube ich, noch erklären für alle diejenigen, die es nicht gesehen haben.
Genau, er ist ja gewechselt. Er ist jetzt erst der vierte Spieler, der sofort im ersten Derby getroffen hat, nachdem er den Verein gewechselt hat. Das ist davor noch so Herren wie Ronaldo mal gelungen und auch Ibrahimovic. Und er hat eigentlich meist damit kokettiert, dass er ja kein Problem mit den Milan-Fans hat, wo er aber nie einen groß guten Stand hatte, weil er wirklich inkonstant gespielt hat. Und er hatte vorher angekündigt, dass er jubeln wird und hat dann auch danach gesagt, na klar, ich habe ganz normal gejubelt, allerdings. Er hat halt einen Elfmetertor gemacht und dann ist dann auch mit dieser ich-kann-euch-nicht-hören-Geste in Richtung der Kurva Sud gelaufen. Das war ein bisschen überzogen. Und da gab es auch in den sozialen Medien den einen oder anderen Kommentar, der gemeint hat, na gut, das ist ja mal schön für dich, wenn du ein Spiel gut machst, wo du dich motivieren kannst. Und viel Spaß in den nächsten drei, vier guten Spielen, die du machst für Inter über die gesamte Saison. Und da kann ich den AC-Fans schon auch irgendwie folgen, denn das war ein Problem von ihm, sowohl bei Milan, aber auch jetzt in der Anfangsphase bei Inter. Er hat gleich direkt getroffen im ersten Spiel bei Inter, aber er tut sich schon sehr schwer in Spielen, in denen es vielleicht mal nicht so spektakulär wird, dann auch dem Ganzen seinen Stempel aufzudrücken. Also man erkennt da oft eine gewisse Lethargie. Es soll jetzt gar nicht irgendwie ein Vergleich sein mit hängenden Schultern bei Özil oder so, sondern es ist wirklich so, dass Cialanullu nicht immer abliefert und da schon Angriffsfläche bietet, in jedem Fall.
Wie ist denn da die Situation, wenn wir mal kurz bei Inter bleiben, die Cialanullu wurde ja unter anderem als Christian Eriksen-Ersatz geholt. Gibt es da eigentlich irgendwelche Neuigkeiten? Denn ich habe von diesem Thema gar nichts mehr gehört.
Neuigkeiten in dem Sinne auf jeden Fall nicht. Da müsste es für ihn, dass er nochmal da spielen dürfte, auf jeden Fall auch eine Gesetzesänderung geben in Italien, dass er dann eben mit so einem Herzschrittmacher spielen dürfte. Da habe ich jetzt schon längere Zeit nichts von gehört. Wobei auch Eriksen, das war zwar noch unter Konter, nie der ganz große Faktor bei Inter war. Auch noch in der Zeit, als er gesund war, da war er meist ein Ergänzungsspieler, weil er nicht ganz so gut reingepasst hat in das sehr intensive Pressing und auch hohe Verteidigungen. Das konnte Mark, da hat er ihn irgendwie meist eher als klassische Zehn gesehen, die er nicht zwingend gebrauchen konnte. Wobei, mit den Attributen hat man mit Cialanulli ja jetzt keinen unähnlichen Spieler. Der ist auch jetzt nicht einer, der die ganze Zeit wie wild draufgeht. Aber insgesamt haben sie einen sehr, sehr guten Kader und werden da auch noch oben weiterhin dranbleiben. Sie haben sich selber ein bisschen nach dem Spiel darüber geärgert, dass sie es nicht gewonnen haben. Das kann man nachvollziehen, dass sie ja dann noch den Elfmeter verschossen haben. Lautaro Martinez, der hat den zweiten treten dürfen. Das ist eigentlich auch der Nummer-1-Elfmeterschütze. Das war wahrscheinlich –vielleicht hat sich auch Hakan da in der zehnten Minute so stark gefühlt, dass er gesagt hat, er will ihn unbedingt nehmen –hat es dann sogar besser gemacht als Lautaro. Aber gerade die ersten 45 war Inter klar besser. Wenn man die Schlussphase betrachtet, war das Unentschieden aus neutraler Sicht, wie ich finde, schon gerechtfertigt. Aber es sind jetzt trotzdem sieben Punkte Rückstand für Inter auf Milan und Napoli. Dennoch ist noch alles in der Reihe, würde ich sagen, weil da gerade Napoli auch ab und an, wie ich finde, ein bisschen überperformt. Und Inter muss man zugute halten, dass sie dieses Jahr die Doppelbelastung viel besser meistern und in der Champions League sehr viel besser dastehen als der Stadtrivale, der da doch in der Königsglasse sehr, sehr enttäuschend aufgetreten ist, wie ich finde.
Aber dafür halt in der Liga noch diese weiße Weste hat. Also Milan und Napoli sind nach zwölf Spielen beide noch ungeschlagen, haben eine identische Bilanz. Zehn Siege, zwei Unentschieden, entsprechend auch Punkt gleich. Wollte man nach einem Unterschied suchen, dann ist der sehr einfach zu finden, nämlich bei den kassierten Toren. Da hat Napoli nämlich –Achtung, ganz genau zuhören, liebe Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer –am zwölften Spieltag hat der SSC Neapel vier Gegentore kassiert. Da müssen wir gleich drüber sprechen. Lass aber noch kurz beim AC Milan bleiben. Du hast ja auch schon von einem Rekord gesprochen, den man damit eingestellt hat. Was sind denn die Dinge, die bei Milan gerade gut laufen, wenn es eben jetzt um die Liga geht?
Also sie haben unheimlich gut, wie ich finde, das System, das Piolli spielen lässt, verinnerlicht. Sie hatten immer wieder, das ist wahrscheinlich dann auch der Faktor bei der Doppelbelastung, Personalsorgen. Es war Praim Dias, der sehr, sehr wichtig ist in der Offensive hinter den Spitzen. Er ist mit Corona eine Zeit lang ausgefallen. Es ist auch keiner, der die zwölf Spiele über 90 Minuten macht. Der kommt jetzt langsam erst so wieder rein, hat aber auch schon Spiele entschieden, wie zum Beispiel das in Rom bei AS. Aber da haben sie eben mit Chirou, der meist auch irgendwie, glaube ich, ein bisschen zu schlecht wegkommt, in der Gesamtbetrachtung eingeholt, der sofort funktioniert hat am Anfang, der in den ersten drei Heimspielen immer getroffen hat. Das ist vor ihm zuletzt mal Mario Balotelli und einem gewissen Oliver Bierhoff gelungen. Im Trikot der Rossoneri. Also da stimmt schon alles zusammen und sie haben ein sehr, sehr gutes Mannschaftsgefüge, wie ich finde. Da ist keiner dabei, der sie irgendwie rausnimmt. Das heißt, ein Ibra, der die Spieler wirklich eher so in eine Rolle des Mentors, wie zum Beispiel für Raphael Leao, den Flügelspieler, ist er sehr wichtig. Das hat er des Öfteren auch betont als Mentor oder vielleicht spielender Trainer, die alle noch besser macht. Und sie schaffen es einfach sehr, sehr gut, sowohl nach hinten als auch vorne. Das Umschaltspiel ist eine große Stärke bei ihnen. Nach hinten vielleicht sogar noch besser als nach vorne meist. Ich finde deswegen, ich meine, Napoli mit vier ist natürlich exzellent verteidigt, aber bei Milan sind es ja auch erst elf und da gab es zwei Spiele, wo sie zwei kassiert haben, wenn ich es richtig im Kopf habe. Also das ist schon auch alles sehr stabil, was sie anstellen. Und sie sind nach dem Vergleich zu den Jahren davor auch in den Topspielen echt immer da. Also der Auftritt bei der Roma und Mourinho war mit das beste Spiel, das sie gemacht haben in dieser Saison. Und deswegen halte ich sie für insgesamt auch gefestigter und für den größeren Titelanwärter als Napoli.
Spannend. Dann lass noch kurz über Napoli sprechen. Wir haben das letzte Mal länger über sie gesprochen mit Christian Bernhard. Damals hatten sie acht Siege aus acht Spielen. Wir haben damals über Viktor Ossimen schon viel gesprochen. Christian hat ihn als Naturgewalt bezeichnet, über Standardsituationen mit ungewöhnlichen Laufwegen. Und schon damals –kein Wunder –haben wir über die defensive Stabilität gesprochen. Hat sich denn irgendetwas jetzt verändert? Oder rauscht halt Napoli einfach weiter so mit seinem Ding, das man da so macht, durch die Liga durch?
Ich würde sagen, es wird ein bisschen knapper. Die letzten zwei Partien haben das gezeigt. Beim Aufsteiger Salahnitana hat man nur mit 1 zu 0 gewonnen. Und das war auch nicht wirklich überzeugend. Da war das Team von Ribery zeitweise wirklich sogar das bessere. Es spricht für Napoli, dass sie es weiterhin sehr geduldig dann immer angehen. Also sie werden nicht hektisch oder verzweifelt. Allerdings lassen sie auch –und das hat man in den letzten Jahren immer wieder zum Vorwurf gemacht –zu viele Chancen liegen. Verteidigend hinten dann aber nach wie vor gut. Und jetzt am Wochenende auch nur 1-1 gegen Hellers. Da ist man dann das erste Mal in den letzten 15 Minuten so ein bisschen verzweifelt, als auch mehrsens dann noch einen Freistoß an Pfosten gesetzt hat. Ich finde, da ist es nicht mehr ganz so überzeugend. Und ich bin sehr gespannt auf die Wintermonate, wo dann eben erst mal Abwehr, Säule, Coulibaly und eben auch Ozymen vermutlich vier, fünf oder sogar im schlimmsten Fall sechs Ligaspiele fehlen, weil sie zum Afrika Cup reisen.
Ja, das kommt dann an der Stelle natürlich wieder mit dazu. Da hast du völlig recht. Also Napoli, aktuell sieht das noch wunderbar aus. Wenn ich mir die Tabelle der Serie A angucke, dann habe ich das Gefühl, da hat sich jetzt gar nicht so viel getan im Vergleich zur letzten Ligatur, die wir hatten. Was jetzt die Plätze angeht. Bei der Roma kann man zwar über zwei Niederlagen sprechen, das haben wir jetzt aber indirekt sogar schon ein bisschen getan. Wer sind denn für dich so die Überraschungsmannschaften, die man nicht auf dem Schirm hat in der Serie A?
Also, wen man auf jeden Fall sich mal anschauen kann, ist Empoli, die als Aufsteiger mit 16 Punkten wirklich im gesicherten Mittelfeld stehen, die das sehr, sehr gut machen, die immer auch den Anspruch haben, ihren eigenen Spielstil durchzudrücken, der sehr viele offensiven Elemente hat, wie sie es auch schon in der Serie B gespielt haben. Das macht großen Spaß. Aber auch ein Platz drüber Hellas Verona, die jetzt am Wochenende mit 1 zu 1 bei Napoli bestanden haben, obwohl sie am Schluss nur noch zu neunt waren. Und da hat jetzt der Simeone Junior seinen neunten Saison-Tor bereits geschossen. So viele hatten noch keinen Hellas Spieler zu dem Zeitpunkt auf der Anzeigetafel. Und die haben früher den Trainer gewechselt. Und die sind unter Tudor, der letztes Jahr noch Kot von… Jetzt hitze ich auf den Namen von Juve. Der größte von allen. Pirlo, so heißt er. Co von Pirlo, wo sie schon scherzhaft sagen, da hätte Juve eigentlich gar nicht Allegri zurückholen müssen. Da liefert Tudor wirklich gute Arbeit in Verona ab. Aber gerade auch in dem Tabellensegment die Fiorentina, jetzt am Wochenende verloren, gegen Juventus, aber mit Vlahovic, ein richtig krasser Stürmer, der hat jetzt 25 Tore im Kalenderjahr 21 erzielt. Das war vor dem Duell gegen Juve ein lustiger Fun-Fact. Also wenn man CR7 herausnimmt, mehr Treffer als der gesamte Juve-Sturm mit Murata Kieser und Di Balla zusammen. Der wird aber aller Voraussicht nach nicht noch allzu lange bei Florenz spielen. Den will Juve unbedingt haben. Die Fiorentina, die aber keine guten Erfahrungen hat mit Transfers zu Juve. Man erinnert sich vielleicht an Roberto Baccio. Seitdem ist die Rivalität zwischen den zwei Vereinen auch sehr hoch. Also die Fiorentina will den ganz gerne auf die Insel verkaufen. Es gehört, dass Tottenham da auch mit im Geschäft ist. Vielleicht dann einer, den Uli in Zukunft gerne beobachten wird. Das ist auch eine –vielleicht mal um Christian Bernhard zu zitieren –eine Naturgewalt mit Ossie-Man, aber vielleicht noch ein bisschen kompakter, noch der krassere Neuner in der Box drin. Das ist ein Stürmer, der alles mitbringt, gerade glaube ich auch für die Premier League. Und Bologna hat sich gefangen nach einer Schwächephase, das Team von Sinisa Mihailović. Und da läuft ja noch ein gewisser Marco Anatović rum. Das finde ich eh auch immer aus mehreren Aspekten interessant, dem beim Fußballspielen zuzugucken. Man bekommt immer irgendwas, was unterhaltsam ist. Ob fußballerisch oder eben emotional über seine Art und Weise, wie er ist.
Ja, das sind doch einige interessante Namen gewesen, die du da noch genannt hast. Und dann lass noch ein kurzes Wort zumindest zu einer der Überraschungen verlieren, dass Juve immer noch nicht so wirklich aufholen konnte. Als wir das letzte Mal gesprochen haben, da hatten sie vier Siege in Serie und konnten damit mit Napoli Schritt halten. Jetzt weiß man gar nicht, ob man überhaupt noch diesen Blick auf Tabellenplatz 1 machen sollte, denn das sind 14 Punkte. Juve aus den letzten vier Liga-Spielen, zwei Niederlagen, ein Unentschieden und jetzt nur ein Sieg, den man jetzt am Wochenende geholt hat. Gibt es da Neuigkeiten, was die Probleme bei Juve sind, oder sind die Probleme die Alten?
Es fehlen wirklich jetzt die Tore von CR7, muss man sagen. Ich hatte zu Beginn gedacht, das würde ihnen ganz gut tun, dass er geht, dass man sich da mehr auf ein Rebuild einlassen kann. Aber gerade in den Phasen, wo es gar nicht über die Mannschaft läuft, fehlt da seine Qualität auf jeden Fall. Sie schießen zu wenig Tore. Sie bekommen kaum Tempo im Schlusstrittel, auch auf den Außen. Jetzt das Tor gegen Florenz, das war dann mal so eine Einzelaktion von Quadrado, der das eigentlich alles mitbringen würde. Und Quesa wird es ja eigentlich auch mitbringen. Aber ich glaube, da sind gerade im Management sehr viele Fehler in Kaderplanung begangen worden. Und ich bin mir auch nicht sicher, ob dann Alegri genau der Richtige ist, um das irgendwie umzuwerfen. Und wenn du dann da noch Ronaldo rausnimmst, wird es eine sehr, sehr schwere Saison. Sie haben aber immer wieder gezeigt, dass sie es stabil jetzt hinten gestalten können. Der Licht verbessert sich stark. Sie haben sich in der Champions League bereits jetzt für das Achtelfinale qualifiziert, mit vier Siegen. Das kann auf jeden Fall noch mal einen Push geben. Und ja, dann müssen sie in der Liga mal ab und an wieder mehr von diesen 1-0, wie jetzt gegen Florenz am Wochenende so abgezockten, Juve-Siegen abliefern. Und dann kann das, glaube ich, auch immer noch für die Qualifikation für die Champions League reichen. Aber ganz nach oben, das hat Allegri auch schon gesagt, dass die Meisterschaft darüber müssen wir überhaupt nicht mehr reden.
Ja, vielleicht auch an der Stelle –das hört sich ein bisschen paradox an, aber vielleicht muss man bei den letzten vier Spielen, die ich da zitiert habe, auch jeweils die Gegner angucken. Denn ich würde sagen, da waren viele Mannschaften der Stunde mit dabei. Also eben gegen Hellers hat man 2 zu 1 verloren, obwohl West McKennie da in der 80. noch den Anschlusstreffer erzielt hat, wo eben besagte Simeone die beiden Treffer für Verona gemacht hat. Dann hat man gegen Sassuolo gewonnen, die zwar in der Saison, nach dem, was ich jetzt so ganz aus dem Augenwinkel verfolgt habe, nicht ganz so überraschend gut spielen, wie es schon mal war in der Serie A, aber ja immer noch eine gute Mannschaft ist, auch wenn das zu Hause war. Und dann gegen Inter, über Inter haben wir schon gesprochen, bei allen kleineren Problemen, die es da gibt, spielen die auch eine sehr gute Saison. Also das kommt dann vielleicht noch bei der Bewertung von Juwel mit dazu, glaube ich.
Ja, das im jeden Fall. Es kann nicht ihr Anspruch sein, das auch, aber es war jetzt auch nicht komplett alles tiefdunkelschwarz, muss man sagen.
Tja, das ist ja erstaunlich, dass es auch bei Juwel kein Schwarz-Weiß-Denken gibt. Wer den Gerg jetzt verstanden hat, herzliche Grüße. Gut, dann fehlt uns noch eine Liga. Wir wollen mit Uli Hebel…
Ich würde noch ganz gerne kurz, weil ich den Namen erwähnt hatte. Also es lohnt sich auf jeden Fall noch. Das habe ich gerade eben, als du mich gefragt hast, nicht bedacht. Aber es lohnt sich auf jeden Fall, mal die nächsten Wochen in Genua zu verfolgen, weil da ja Andriy Shevchenko jetzt neuer Trainer ist. Beim ältesten Club Italiens. Neunmal Meister geworden. Das letzte Mal war, glaube ich, irgendwann in den 30ern, wenn nicht sogar 20er-Jahren. Aber das halte ich für eine hochspannende Personalie. Da ist Davide Ballardini gegangen worden. Zum insgesamt vierten Mal bei Genua. Der hat insgesamt in seiner Trainerlaufbahn es nur einmal geschafft, vom ersten bis zum letzten Spieltag bei einem Verein zu sein. Also das ist der Peter Neurower Italiens. Oder wie auch immer. Und das könnte ich mir sehr, sehr spannend vorstellen. Genua, also der CFC, ist ein Club, der vielleicht nicht der beste erste Verein für einen Trainer ist. Also ich meine, der war jetzt lange bei der Ukraine Nationaltrainer, Chefchenko, aber noch nie in der Liga. Aber sie haben einen Präsidenten, der sehr sprunghaft ist, Enrico Preziosi. Vielleicht hat man den Namen schon mal gehört. Ihm gehört eine große Spielwaren-Unternehmen, Ciochi Preziosi. Also und der Verein ist meistens auch irgendwie Spielzeug von ihm gewesen. Aber er hat im September jetzt die großen Anteile des Vereins an ein amerikanisches Unternehmen verkauft. Und sie sind so ein bisschen im Rebuild, haben interessante junge Spieler. Und Goran Pan, der vorne, der ist nicht mehr ganz so jung. Aber da könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass es entweder komplett schiefgeht für Chefchenko oder er, da Vertrag bis 2024 bekommen hat, da wirklich was aufbaut mit ein paar jungen Spielern, haben auch eine sehr, sehr gute Jugendarbeit, oft auch die Primavera, die Jugendmeisterschaft gewonnen. Das könnte ich mir sehr, sehr spannend vorstellen, in den nächsten Wochen das mal zu beobachten, wenn man immer mal wieder vielleicht die Ergebnisse im Blick haben möchte, was Sheva da zusammen mit Goran Pandew in Genoa hinbekommt.
Da hätte ich dann ja nur die wichtige Frage, hat denn Chefchenko seine Co-Trainer mitgenommen? Denn das sind der Italiener, unter anderem Mauro Tassotti, der von 2001 bis 2014 bei Milan Co-Trainer war. Na, da ist auf jeden Fall auch eine Italien-Connection da. Wer sich an die EM-Vorschau erinnert, da haben wir das damals auch schon thematisiert. Und man hatte es ja bei der Ukraine auch gesehen, allerdings nicht so sehr bei der EM selbst, sondern in den Vorbereitungsspielen dazu. Gut, Genoa werden wir im Blick behalten. Jetzt nehmen wir die Premier League als letzte Liga, die uns noch fehlt in den Blick. Uli Hebel darf sich mit einschalten. Tja, Uli, was ist wichtig zu wissen, was sich in der Premier League getan hat?
Ich glaube vor allen Dingen, auf Trainerseiten hat sich einiges getan. Ich weiß gar nicht, wann die letzte Ligatur war. Die Newcastle-Übernahme ist, glaube ich, auch noch nicht besprochen, soweit ich das richtig habe.
Die Übernahme schon, aber noch nicht der Trainerwechsel dort. Damals haben wir noch über Steve Bruce gesprochen und dass er nett ist, aber taktisch vielleicht nicht der Wesierteste.
Klingt nach einem anderen Hebel. Netter Typ, auch ein guter Autor, habe ich mir sagen lassen. Ich habe jetzt die Bücher noch nicht gelesen, wäre ich auch nicht tun. Aber er ist inzwischen nicht mehr Trainer, sondern Eddie Howe, der übernommen hat, dass das eine Personalie, Daniel Fakir, ist bei Neutsch entlassen worden. Zum jetzigen Stand ist der Nachfolger zwar so gut wie sicher, aber noch nicht sicher. Und Aston Villa hat ebenfalls nochmal reagiert, haben auch ihren Trainer entlassen. Auch da gibt es noch keinen Nachfolger. Das sind, glaube ich, jetzt die, die im Moment obergeordneten oder übergeordneten, das wäre das richtige deutsche Wort, das ich gesucht habe, Personalien. Und dann gibt es ja noch eine zumindest, die in England sozusagen täglich observiert wird, spätestens jetzt auch nach der neuerlichen Niederlage im Manchester Derby, nämlich die von Oligo nach Solskjaer. Da ist aber nichts passiert und ich gehe auch nicht davon aus, dass noch was passiert.
Ja gut, also Solskjaer, das würde ich fast ein bisschen einklammern, wenn ich irgendwie 10 Euro bekommen würde. Jedes Mal, wenn der in Frage stand in der Premier League in Medien, dann wäre ich ein sehr reicher Mensch. Ja, lass mal dann gerne die Personalien durchgehen. Das, was man hier in Deutschland mitbekommen hat, war natürlich die Entlassung von Fakir bei Norwich City. Ironischerweise oder paradoxerweise vielleicht viel eher nach dem ersten Sieg dieses Teams bei Brentford. Einer der Überraschungsmannschaften über Brentford haben wir hier ja schon viel geschwärmt in der Ligatur. Wie würdest du das denn jetzt einschätzen? Norwich mit fünf Punkten, aktuell fünf Punkte, dann auch hinter dem rettenden Ufer?
Ja, komischer Zeitpunkt, aber das heißt für mich, dass Norwich, also die Director of Football, Stuart Webber, der auch David Wagner zu Huddersfield geholt hat und da schon für das erste kleine Wunder verantwortlich war und hat er dann mit Norwich das Ganze jetzt zum zweiten Mal hingebracht in diesem Sommer, dass sie aufgestiegen sind. Ich gehe davon aus, dass der schon vorher sich dessen bewusst war, was er machen will. Alles andere wäre ja nicht besonders sinnvoll gewesen. Ich mag es auch irgendwie nachvollziehen. Das muss man, glaube ich, sehr stark zweiteilen, diese Entlassung Farkes jetzt. Weil auf der einen Seite ist er überhaupt erst der Grund, dass Norwich noch existiert. Das muss man so deutlich sagen. Die waren wirklich am Rande der Pleite, mal wieder. Das hatte auch schon eine gewisse Tradition da. Und hat dann in seiner Zweitliga-Zeit noch, damals von BVB 2 hat er hingewechselt, Spieler verpflichtet aus der deutschen 2. Liga oder teils sogar 3. Liga, die dort nicht mehr Verträge bekommen haben. Und deshalb günstig, also auch was die Personalkosten betrifft, zu holen waren, zu haben waren, hat die dort bei Norwich eingepflegt, hat gepflegten Fußball entwickelt, ist dann aufgestiegen. Dann sind sie bitterböse abgestiegen in der ersten Premier League-Saison. Die waren, muss man ehrlich sagen, von März bis Mai eine wirkliche Lachnummer. In der Liga waren also vorne und hinten nicht wettbewerbsfähig. Und sind dann aber mit einem veränderten Ansatz in der zweiten Liga rekordhaft aufgestiegen. Und ich meinte eigentlich auch, dass sie mit den Transfers, die sie im Sommer gemacht haben, okay vorbereitet sind. Soweit es geht mit dem Budget, das sie haben, das ist halt deutlich, deutlich weniger. Also nur mal so zum Vergleich. Die Besitzerin, das sind TV-Kirchen, die soll rund 40 Millionen in etwa auf der hohen Kante haben. Und das ist ja ein Tagesgehalt von einem Newcastle-Besitzer sozusagen. Das heißt, das muss man schon auch nochmal einschätzen jetzt im Vergleich. Auch wenn natürlich da mit Rashica zum Beispiel schon auch jemand geholt worden ist, der so an der 10-Millionen-Grenze war, ist jetzt nicht so, dass die arm sind. Aber für Premier League-Verhältnisse halt schon. Und dann muss man aber die Saison nochmal sehen, so wie sie war. Und ich habe einige Spiele gesehen von Neusch auch nochmal, auch intensiver mir das angeguckt. Und mir fehlt ja schon ein ganzes Stück weit die Fantasie, wie das klappen soll, weil sie recht deutsch spielen jetzt inzwischen, umschalten wollen. Aber viele verschiedene Grundformationen, die Faker ausprobiert hat. Viele verschiedene Spieler auch, die er in diesen Grundformationen hat. Das möchte ich immer gar nicht so überbewerten. Aber die Spieler, die dann ordnende Dinge machen sollen, sind stark gewechselt bei ihm. Insgesamt sowieso eine hohe Fluktuation. Und immer noch eine starke Abhängigkeit von Temo Pucki, was vielleicht in dessen Alter jetzt auch nicht mehr ganz so glücklich ist, wenn es so zu sein hat. Und deswegen kann ich jetzt von der Spielweise her kommend mir das irgendwie schön saufen, dass diese Entlassung passiert ist. Aber rein, wenn man die letzten Jahre bei Neusch und dem, was passiert ist, seit Faker da ist und was er eigentlich diesem Verein gebracht hat und wie verdient er sich gemacht hat, dann mag man es irgendwie nicht verstehen. Also ganz schwierig, das zu bewerten.
Ja, interessante Perspektive, auch mit dem, was du sagst, dass Norwich einen, in Anführungszeichen, deutschen Fußballspiel, das ist ja auch dann eigentlich interessant zu sehen, wie das in einer anderen Liga funktioniert. Das sage ich aber natürlich als jemand, der den deutschen Fußball sehr, sehr, sehr intensiv verfolgt für den Rasenfunk. Also das war eine der Entlassungen. Dann hast du Newcastle United schon angesprochen. Da gab es auch viel Berichterstattung drüber, die zumindest auch bei mir aufgeschlagen ist. David Hau ist jetzt da der neue Trainer geworden. Was ist denn von ihm und von Newcastle generell zu erwarten? Die Aufregung ist nicht wirklich geringer geworden in den letzten Wochen.
Also ich mag den Trainer sehr gerne. Lange Jahre bei Bournemouth gearbeitet, zwischenzeitlich hat er es mal woanders probiert, aber nie glücklich geworden da. Und ich vertrete immer die Meinung, wenn der ein Ausländer wäre, dann hätte er einen viel, viel besseren Stand in England gehabt, weil der sensationelle Arbeit zum Teil mit einem äußerst limitierten Kader bei Bournemouth geleistet hat. Und mich hat es bis heute erstaunt, dass nie ein Klub, der einen Trainer gesucht hat, an ihn ernsthaft ran zu gehen, schien. Also es hätte durchaus auch mal sein können, dass Tottenham eventuell überlegt oder Everton. Das wären so klassisch Klubs, von denen ich gedacht hätte, dass sie vielleicht mal an den denken. Das ist ein sehr smarter Typ. Das ist ein nicht immer ganz lauter, aber vor allen Dingen sehr, sehr fleißiger Trainer, der viel über Standards kommt, also wirklich die absoluten Basics seinen Spielern mitgibt und dann aber auch gerne recht schnell nach vorne denkt. Also es ist ein geflügeltes Zitat. Da ist er jetzt auch nicht der Einzige, wahrscheinlich dem das anzuhaften ist, aber dass er sagt, ich gewinne lieber Spieler, als dass ich versuche, sie nicht zu verlieren. Und das hat ganz gut gezeigt, was er mit Bournemouth getan hat. Okay, letztlich dann abgestiegen, aber das war ja auch irgendwann nur eine Frage der Zeit, dass du mit diesem Kader, mit dieser Mannschaft absteigen musst, ist jetzt bei Newcastle. Ich meine, ehrlicherweise ist Newcastle –das Problem war, sie haben mit den letzten Trainern –und Rafa Benitez ist ein ausgezeichneter, deswegen hat es nie Probleme gegeben –aber Steve Bruce versuchte, ein Defensiv-Team zu coachen. Dafür waren sie aber deutlich zu schlecht organisiert und deswegen haben sie viele Gegentore gefangen und waren aber zahlenmäßig sehr, sehr tief gestanden, sodass sie an sich ein bis zwei Offensivspieler hatten. Einer, Saint-Maximin, ist mal überragend und dann vier Spiele lang völlig wild und nicht zu sehen. Und dann kommt wieder ein Harry-Dribbling, das dann zum Teil auch funktioniert, und sie haben vorne drin Carl und Wilson. Aber wenn die beiden abzumelden waren –und Premier League-Isten sind in der Regel smart und haben das recht schnell gemacht –dann gab es wenig mit Newcastle. Das heißt, so wie dieser Kader, der in den letzten Jahren auch wenig verstärkt worden ist, so wie dieser Kader bislang gespielt hat, weiß ich noch gar nicht richtig, das abzubilden, was Hau jetzt versuchen wird, mit diesem Kader zu tun. Und ich meine, ganz so lang wird er sich mit dem auch nicht mehr beschäftigen müssen, weil in rund zwei Monaten wird er ja auf Shopping-Tour gehen dürfen und wird dann sicherlich auch zumindest ein paar völlig überteuerte Transfers in den Kader inkludieren dürfen.
Und glaubst du, das kann er? Kann man das bewerten mit seinen Trainerstationen? Bornmuth hast du genannt, Burnley dazwischen?
Ich hoffe, dass er es nicht alleine machen muss, wenn ich ehrlich bin, weil das bedeuten würde, dass Newcastle bis zu dem Zeitpunkt noch immer gar keinen Director of Football hat. Und Amanda Stavely, die jetzt sozusagen als Gesicht des Vereins aufgebaut wird, die hat, glaube ich, selber Lust, Sportdirektorin zu spielen. Das hat sie aber nicht im Kreuz sportlich gesehen. Deswegen würde ich mir, ich glaube, das wäre sogar auch die wichtigere Position, dass sie jetzt recht schnell jemanden finden, der sich darum kümmern wird, dem Verein eine Strategie zu geben, gerade weil eben so viel Geld da ist. Ansonsten werden sie drei, vier Tote sterben, bevor es dann irgendwann mal in die richtige Richtung geht oder bevor Saudi Arabien vielleicht auch gar keinen Bock mehr hat drauf. Also aus Sicht Newcastles wäre das, glaube ich, das Empfehlenswert, dass sie so schnell wie möglich jetzt da einen Plan reinzubekommen. Aber ich traue es trotzdem Eddie Howe auch zu, mit seinem Wissen. Und er hat mit Jason Tindall eine ausgezeichnete Nummer 2, der ihm dann auch gefolgt ist bei Bournemouth, kurz als Cheftrainer. Das war nicht so sein Ding. Aber er hat eine ausgezeichnete Nummer 2 da. Ich denke schon, dass die beiden in der Lage sind, Spieler zu identifizieren. Vielleicht aber, und das ist ja das Newcastle, da geht die Öffentlichkeit davon aus. Und ich glaube, die Besitzer schafft auch, dass die jetzt ganz schnell die ganz großen Namen holen werden. Ich würde denken, dass Eddie Howe smart genug ist, um genau das nicht zu tun, sondern jetzt erstmal Funktionsspieler holt, die sein System weiterbringen, dass er da implementieren will. Und da ist eine Menge zu tun, weil der Kader ist nicht besonders stark.
Kurze Frage von mir an dich, Uli. Findest du, Eddie Howe ist da die richtige, die schlüssige, die gute Wahl für Newcastle? Oder hätte Newcastle ins höhere Trainerregal greifen müssen?
Ich habe es ja ganz kurz schon mal vorhin angedeutet. Ich halte den durchaus, wenn man in Regalen denken mag, den mindestens ein, zwei Kasten höher als in der, in der letztlich geschoben wird. Ich freue mich, dass der wieder zurück ist in der Liga. Ich habe dessen Fußball immer sehr geschätzt. Ich habe immer gefunden, dass er mit seinen Teams klar overperformed hat in allen Ligen im Übrigen. Also hat sie auch perfekt angepasst an seine Umgebungen jeweils. Und deswegen freue ich mich, dass er jetzt da ist. Ich weiß nicht, ob der Typ, so wie er als Mensch zu sein scheint, ich kenne ihn ja jetzt nicht persönlich, aber so wie er als Mensch zu sein scheint, ob der dann mit diesem riesengroßen und jetzt ganz unorganisch wachsenden Umfeld klarkommt. Da habe ich noch ein paar Fragezeichen. Aber ich meine, das muss er halt jetzt lernen. Und ich bin einfach froh, dass er in der Premier League ist, weil der gehört dahin.
Und dann haben wir noch Aston Villa, die du genannt hast. Die haben nach Jack Greelish im Sommer jetzt auch ihren Trainer Dean Smith verloren. Hängt beides miteinander zusammen?
Ja, also nicht nur. Aber das ist schon ein ganz, ganz großer Grund, dass Jack Greelish so ziemlich alles bestimmt hat. Und vor allen Dingen das Spiel bei Aston Villa. Und den haben sie versucht zu ersetzen, auch mit ordentlich viel Geld zu ersetzen. Aber der Spieler, der –also eins zu eins geht eh nicht. Das kann sich Aston Villa auch nicht leisten. Bei all dem Geld, das da dahinter steckt, kommt ein solcher Spieler nicht nach Birmingham. Noch nicht, mag sich noch ändern, aber noch nicht. Und Buendia, den sie verpflichtet haben, ja, reicht nicht. Also der kommt aus der zweiten englischen Liga. Da war er wirklich alles überragend. Hat auch in der Premier League schon in der Saison davor gezeigt, dass er kreativ sein kann und so weiter. Aber eher von der rechten Seite kommen. Der musste eine etwas zentralere Rolle bei Villa einnehmen. Das hat nicht funktioniert. Und dazu kommen einige auch individuelle Formschwächen jetzt im Vergleich zur letzten Saison. Dann auch Dean Smith, der angefangen hat, seine eigenen Überzeugungen über Bord zu werfen. Öfter mal auch gewechselt hat in den Formationen. Schlüsselspieler aus irgendwelchen Gründen aus den Startformationen gezogen hat. Und dann ist da irgendwann eine Gemenge Lage geworden, bei der ich es dann wiederum nachvollziehen kann. Auch da finde ich es irgendwie schade. Und wenn man das jetzt aus der Geschichte begründet, würde man sagen, ihr hattet es jetzt mit Trainer Chaos probiert in den Jahren zuvor. Das hat nicht funktioniert. Jetzt schien es endlich, Stabilität zu geben. Jetzt macht ihr wieder was. Okay. Andererseits sind jetzt nicht nur fünf Niederlagen in Folge, sondern aus den letzten 36 Premier League Spielen haben sie 40 Punkte geholt. Und sie dachten, dass sie einen Schritt machen können und eher in Richtung Europa League ran können. Und da wollen sie mittelfristig hin. Und deswegen kann ich sogar verstehen, dass man da jetzt sagt, wenn man die Ergebnisse sieht und aber auch die Art und Weise, wie sie zum Teil entstanden sind, dann kann ich das sogar halbwegs nachvollziehen. Und letzter Satz dazu vielleicht auch noch. Dean Smith hatte nach dieser Übernahme von diesem neuen Konsortium, die unter anderem auch die Finger bei den Milwaukee Bucks in der NBA drin haben, und die sind ja bekanntlich Meister geworden in der vergangenen Saison, entsprechend schnell möchten die da an sich auch vorankommen. Die haben nie gedacht, dass Dean Smith der Name ist, der sie weiterbringen könnte, sondern die haben den immer nur als Transitionstrainer gesehen. Und deswegen, glaube ich, ist die Entscheidung auch nicht so schwergefallen. Der Finger war permanent schon am Abzug.
Ja, das fasst das, glaube ich, ganz gut zusammen. Willa baut uns so ein bisschen die Brücke auch zu zwei Niederlagen, die jetzt am letzten Spieltag, dem 11. passiert sind, die viel diskutiert wurden. Nein, Entschuldigung, nicht zu... Da war ich im falschen Tap. Manchester United hat ja viel früher schon gegen B ja verloren. Da kommt ja der Sieg her. Das hatte ich mir einfach falsch gemerkt. Aber sowohl United als auch Liverpool haben ihre letzten Spiele verloren. Lass mal bei Liverpool anfangen, denn bei Manchester United habe ich das Gefühl, wir wiederholen uns irgendwie in letzter Zeit so ein bisschen. Wie ist denn das einzuordnen? Das letzte Mal, als wir über Liverpool gesprochen haben, waren sie doch absolut überzeugend. Sowohl international als auch national schienen oder scheinen für mich –ich möchte das jetzt gar nicht in die Vergangenheit schon setzen –eine der besten Mannschaften Europas aktuell zu sein. Eine Niederlage kann ja auch mal passieren. Was für eine Art von Niederlage war es denn?
Ja, ich glaube schon eine, die man einfach auch da reinrechnen muss. Irgendwann muss es halt mal passieren. Jetzt haben sie, glaube ich, 26 in Folge nicht verloren. Jetzt kommt West Ham, die ganz viele Dinge ganz richtig machen im Moment und auch noch mal gezeigt haben. Das würde ich in dem Fall sogar vorne dran stellen. Das ist keine Liverpool-Schwäche. Das war jetzt definitiv nicht ganz sauber. Das war nicht der allerkonzentrierteste Auftritt. Das Timing in den Pressing-Sequenzen hat nicht so gepasst. Die Auslöser nicht richtig gesehen. Dann ist ja ganz oft ein Tag schon so richtig gebraucht, wenn das so passiert für Liverpool. Aber auf der anderen Seite –und das ist, glaube ich, viel hervorhebenswerter –war es eine unglaublich starke Performance. Vielleicht sogar auch die stärkste jetzt in den letzten beiden Jahren unter David Moyes, in denen Dinge passiert sind, die ich bis heute nicht glauben kann, weil ich David Moyes eigentlich schon als Dead Man Walking hatte im gesamten englischen Fußball. Und erstaunlich, was der aus West Ham gemacht hat. Deswegen würde ich die Ligenanlage Liverpools nicht allzu hoch hängen. Im Gegenteil, ich habe sie nach wie vor in dem Cluster drin. Und da hatte ich sie ja vor der Saison nicht unbedingt bei den Top-Dreien, die es letztlich in Sachen Meisterschaft unter sich entscheiden werden, Chelsea City und eben Liverpool.
Also fürs Tabellenbild noch kurz, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, Chelsea Platz 1 mit 26 Punkten, jetzt auch nur unentschieden gespielt. Am Wochenende City und West Ham mit 23 Punkten dahinter, Liverpool 22 Punkte. Das heißt, 4 Punkte Rückstand aktuell auf Chelsea. Und auf Rang 5 noch ganz kurz, Uli, der FC Arsenal. Die haben sich so ein kleines Särchen aufgebaut und sind jetzt längere Zeit ungeschlagen und haben sich damit mit der spektakulären Tordifferenz von 13 zu 13 auf Rang 5 vorgeschoben. Alles wieder gut?
Ja, im Moment sieht es so aus. Wir hatten ja das letzte Mal gesprochen, als sie zur ersten Länderspielpause ganz am Ende der Tabelle standen. Mit, ich glaube, was waren das, 0 zu 9 Toren oder irgendwie so ähnlich. Und sich haben abschießen lassen von Manchester City. Seither –Arteta ist ein cleverer Trainer, das muss man ihm echt lassen. Der hat jetzt ein System für sich gefunden, implementiert, das die richtigen Ergebnisse für den Moment holt und die richtigen Spieler zum richtigen Zeitpunkt in ihre Entwicklungsphase an die Positionen schiebt, wo sie nicht ganz so extrem viel Verantwortung zu übernehmen haben. Und es funktioniert. Und jetzt haben sie sich gegen Watford auch in dem Spiel mal zur Wehr gesetzt, dass sie typischerweise noch vor Monaten verloren hätten, weil sie einfach nicht so mit dem ständigen Druck klargekommen wären. Das haben sie jetzt 1 vor allem zu 0 gewonnen. Und deswegen ist da der Befund für den Moment äußerst positiv. Das war ja nicht immer so. Das war ja auch schon kurz vor der Entlassung. Aber für den Moment würde ich sagen, Ateta zeigt mir gerade wieder. Und das ist so fies, weil ich den nicht einzuschätzen weiß. Jedes Mal, wenn ich denke, jetzt kenne ich die Wahrheit über ihn, kommt ein ganz neues Kapitel dazu. Aber das spricht ja für ihn, dass der in dieser Trainerstation für sich selbst auch unheimlich viel Erfahrung sammelt.
Also dann werden wir Arsenal einfach weiter genau im Blick behalten. Ich glaube, das macht so ganz gut diese Sendung hier fertig. Ihr vier, ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich für eure Zeit, dass ihr euch hier zugeschaltet habt. Aus aller Herren Länder möchte ich fast sagen. Ganz herzlichen Dank an Uli Hebel. Könnt ihr natürlich auch auf Twitter folgen. Werde ich verlinken in den Show Notes. Danke dir, lieber Uli. Dann danke an Alex Truica, wird natürlich ebenfalls verlinkt. Danke dir, Alex. Gerne. Danke, Mario Rieker, vom Serie Amore Podcast unter anderem. Danke, Mario. Und danke an Alexis Menuge, direkt aus Paris zugeschaltet. Wir hatten immer mal wieder irgendwelche Krähen im Hintergrund, aber sie haben immer an den richtigen Stellen gekräht.
Und danke an mir und an die Kollegen.
Dann euch lieben Dank, liebe Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer. Gebt uns gerne Feedback, wie ihr dieses Format so empfindet. Der Rasenfunk bleibt werbe-, payball- und sponsorenfrei. Wir zahlen unseren Gästen einen Honorar. Das heißt, wenn ihr uns unterstützt, unterstützt ihr auch sie. Auf rasenfunk.de/supporterscluberfahrt ihr, wie ihr das tun könnt. Und ganz herzlichen Dank an alle, die das schon getan haben. In diesem Sinne, bis bald. Passt auf euch auf, bleibt gesund. Und dann hören wir uns bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Egal, ob im Kurzfass oder der Schlusskonferenz.